on the mount for the marlins it is
eliezer hernandez his 2021 season debut
316 era and six starts last year 34
strikeouts the citrus series uh their
geographical rival shakes out it's a
three and three as the first strikeout
of the night for eliezer hernandez he
sets down austin meadows using the
fastball to set up the slider does a
fantastic job of it watch meadows swing
and this one in the air out to center
looks like an easy play for martay two
down
into the postseason
grounded two jazz at second a one two
three inning for eliezer hernandez
aguilar three for seven in this series
bats with two on miggy and marte on the
move it slips out of zunino's hand and
the marlins have two in scoring position
yeah you love the heads up base running
two and two
is in the air to center field this one
should be deep enough to score maggie
kiermeier underneath it his throw will
go to third and the marlins have a one
to nothing lead on the sacrifice fly
from jesus aguilar
i think cooper's done a nice job of
getting the ball in the air boom strike
three call he throws him with that
fastball 90 on the inside corner that is
perfect
breaking ball hit on the ground
sadamas with the throw to get brentson
that's bertie oprah third
up with it to get adamus and it'll keep
diaz at second nice job by john birdie
getting the start at the hot corner
as here is mike zanino i should say
he has to go on contact and contact
there is a deep drive to left field back
and it is princeton peace to the wall it
is gone
mike zanino with his first home run of
2021
it's a two-run shot and the rays have
taken a 2-1 lead here in the second
inning
chisholm junior leading off here going
after the second pitch breaking ball
lifting it into
short left and getting out there to make
a fine catch how about that
by joey wendell retreating out there
from third base
what an angle he had on that one see if
the marlins can push across the
equalizer or more after the two-run
zenino home run to chad wallach who goes
right through a vacated right side of
the infield bertie is coming home he
will score chad wallach ties the game at
two
yeah big red going the opposite way you
gotta love it
[Music]
shot this one toward the corner
they want to hop the wall
wallack
is headed to the plate the throw is
going to get it
he is out at the plate
wallach trying to score from first on
the shot into the corner by rojas and
the rays
cut him down and it's really based on
history more than uh
a wild guess
but perhaps a blister issue we'll see
eric cooper deep drive left field does
it have the legs it does first homer of
the year for the marlins it's garrett
cooper putting them up by a run
now ball if you think back to at bat
number one right rich hill stuck a
fastball by him and i i made the comment
that i think
goop really has set his sights on the
curve ball tonight that's pretty obvious
look at the swing i mean he was tracking
the curveball out of his hand all the
way to the bottom of the zone and great
extension
oh jazz was off early
and he's in there safely
just a tremendous jump and then rich
hill the veteran i'm sure didn't want to
panic or anything he stepped off and
kind of a slow developing play that
leads to an extra 90 feet for jazz folks
at statcast called elite speed it's on
display again as he steals third hey
what personality
what personality
another o2 pitch
head out to right coming in meadows jazz
going to test the arm here's the throw
mark and he's all over the place jazz
chisholm junior
scores cargo has one of those home runs
runners lead it first and second
that's the other way a base hit dropping
in front of cooper
[Applause]
rosso
and the rays get their third run
bundle wants to get some lift and get
this game tied
drives it again and a ground ball
through the left side there's a base hit
to score meadows to tie this game jaundi
diaz
diaz shoots it fair up the right field
side
[Applause]
margot scores
here comes wendell
and the throw to the plate will
not be in time
a head first slide on the landing for
wendell at the plate
as diaz gives the raise a
two-run lead 6-4
into center
it'll
stay up for marty who makes the catch a
sliding grab
and they'll double up diaz placing some
details from a different game right i
just remember that four run inning
this one into right
meadows turns spins and can't get to it
it one hops the wall marte on his way to
third he's getting waved around and
here's the throw not in time
aguilar drives in a run
meadows got twisted around and the
marlins capitalize it's a one-run game
you look at the line score
that may change here we'll see this one
to right center and in and out of the
glove of meadows aguilar rounding third
hill score cooper to second
and some defensive miscues for austin
meadows in right in this inning back to
even at six
hoop with a home run back in the third
bats with the bases juiced in the
seventh rays have the infield in
that is in the right field of base hit
mickey's in to score and marty thought
about it
[Applause]
nearly ran into trey hillman
who was trying to put the brakes on
marlins go station to station and take
the lead
marlins have the lead back and looking
for more
into right falling in front of meadows
and bernie will do just that one run is
in here comes the second john bernie
with a two rbi single and the marlins
stretch their lead
down to third
bertie's throw is off the minute of
aguilar the raves are going to pick up a
run
so that will trim the deficit to two
he'll face adam duvall off the bench for
the marlins
last season with the braves 16 homers
and 33 rbis
and he may have his first marlins home
run right here
with a pinch hit home run
now the marlins doing it a variety of
ways tonight
like this guy
maybe seven yeah you might want to add
to it that one's gonna get down a four
hit night for martay this one's gonna
put another run on the board he's on his
way to third with an rbi triple
bit of an uppercut swing
that's into left-center field of base
hit
heading toward the gap marco cuts it off
cooper heading to second he's in there
with an rbi double
ball and two strikes to meadows swing
and a miss sit for the first time in
2021
it's a marlins win 12-7 the final count